тому-то у нас належить практика
обчислень
ну дієвість за раз на троянди вітри
законопроекти право ще й почету
я думаю colleen за голий рівень
прийняття закону знайти cuy правлячого
светр залі закони і легка пара каються і
будь-який режим дня ванни кого-небудь
реальним і пров'язані дурного жити
вони просто ці землі і які ви можете
ляльок хату ктати
пригвинчується 3 закони я ну як ректор
може сказати ще напишу цей закон з
d розробки ті штуки проректори
40 ківалів і калетник нуцці реальний
закон випадкової поправки далекі до
різних статей ось ми нора директорії
втиратися регіону розгадала і ціль
закону спрямованої на спинку ректора
україни та на коментарі ковані ради
супи тального корі змити і свої по
бажання all оцінок bench завзятий і
реальний закон when we do врожай
реальні карти нові через світло і
дельта річки по і мені терміни екіпу ви не
заробляєте свято дали з tor кільця
porsche автономії ось was able його
фінансової автономії ви шукає начальник
завтра розвитку подальше розвитку
науки ось і так далі до 2а стане два
менших проекти в одній душі схожі
я б сказав ось і нами підлога немає ні душі
вдалині ту ж
бо то не відразу милих струмок ну по
porsche
різанини на проклятому національна комісія
за квіти свищей світляк опа ви на
виграш у цій річці харчування паралельно
з міністерством реакція можна буде і
нетримання орган управління міністерства
на по ви не проводите державну політику
на представити законі на представлені
рішення укази президента без садових
рішення так далі національної комісії
це може бути
мацко організації але це вона не тато
вийде з роботи і пам'ятай рішення які
будуть пл його таємно ви ще й свиту
ось ну і рабське взагалі мета to
keep обожнювання більше як можна його колеса
буду ось ось я ректор такого середнього
регіонального вишу
то я би сказав що інші третій проект
закону ван і розра коні на душі і
великі вузи скажемо про таке національне
масштабі від на середню
щоб вони на розрив його не тому я і
коректори долара directory of teras
коректора бачимо на нашого
ректорського корпусу випадково будемо про
вимагати законники разу був і нашої і
колій народні депутати та 40 ківалову
от і колайдера Михайлович